Обсяги прокачки газу трубопроводом "Північний потік-1"
минулого року залишилися на рівні 2018-го -
близько 58 мільярдів кубометрів,
звітував наприкінці січня оператор газогону.
Водночас з Європи постійно надходять невтішні новини для "Газпрому",
основного акціонера "Північного потоку".
На тлі аномально теплого січня, який зазвичай
є одним з пікових місяців опалювального сезону,
у Європі в цілому впав попит на газ.
Ситуацію погіршило ще й те, що торік, побоюючись припинення транзиту через Україну,
європейські країни закачали рекордні обсяги газу у свої сховища.
Як наслідок - "Газпром" був вимушений скоротити запланований транзит
блакитного палива в Європу через Україну більш ніж удвічі.
У Європі зараз надмір газу, і викликаний він, зокрема,
різким збільшенням закупівель скрапленого природного газу - СПГ.
Імпорт СПГ у Європі минулого року збільшився на майже 90%.
І це не лише і не стільки американський скраплений газ, я
к передусім Катар та Росія,
тобто виходить, російська компанія "Газпром" втрачає,
ле натомість російська компанія "Новотек" навпаки, збільшує свій збут у Європі.
Та зрештою всі постачальники втрачають:
через такий надмір у Європі, що природно, упали ціни на газ.
Крім того, країни Східної Європи намагаються зменшити свою залежність від російського газу.
Болгарія, яка стала одним зі споживачів газу,
що надходить через "Турецький потік",
днями оголосила, що до кінця року постарається замінити
половину поставок з Росії газом
зі США та  Азербайджану.
Польща готова не лише відмовитися
від російського газу з 2022 року,
а й припинити транзит газогоном  "Ямал-Європа".
Термін дії транзитного договору добігає кінця
18 травня, і його подовження під питанням.
У Німеччині, яка отримує газ з Росії напряму,
ситуацію з залежністю розцінюють дещо інакше.
У нинішній ситуації пропозиція на газовому ринку надмірна,
а про залежність можна говорити лише,
якщо немає інших варіантів поставок.
Нині ж, як Німеччина, так і Європа в цілому,
мають вибір.
Ще однією проблемою  "Газпрому" і надалі залишається газопровід "Північний потік-2".
Через американські санкції його будівництво затримається щонайменше на рік,
а добудовувати його доведеться винятково
силами російської сторони.
Крім цього, вимоги європейської енергетичної директиви
можуть позбавити "Газпром" можливості розпоряджатися
"Північним потоком-2" повною мірою.
У січні оператор газопроводу подав заявку
в німецьке Федеральне агентство з мереж із проханням
вивести його з-під дії Газової директиви,
проте єврокомісарка з питань енергетики
Кадрі Сімсон вважає,
що винятків для "Північного потоку-2"
робити не можна.
Ми говоримо не тільки про "Північний потік-2",
а й про всі інші газопроводи, незалежно від того,
де вони починаються.
Якщо вони заходять у Євросоюз, вони повинні відповідати певним вимогам.
Ми перевіряємо дотримання цих правил у співпраці з місцевими регуляторами,
у випадку Німеччини - з федеральним мережевим агентством.
Газова мережа повинна бути відкритою і для третіх постачальників.
Тарифна політика повинна бути зрозумілою,
і газопровід повинен бути відокремлений від виробника.
Запуск Nord Stream 2 неможливий без дотримання цих правил.
Рішення щодо запиту "Північного потоку -2”
в Німеччині мають ухвалити до 24 травня цього року.